hello everyone this is grandma servara
kobien
and i'm working as a grandmaster in
residence for the saint louis chess club
and i'm glad to be back
and i will be presenting you with uh
some end game positions today some very
special
end game studies okay extraordinary
stuff and i hope you will enjoy this
okay
because this is really really great
stuff i'll be showing you today okay
so let's uh take a look okay so we're
gonna start off with
uh the first position okay i'm gonna set
it up for you
and let's go here
this one is white to play
white to play and win so let's see if
you can do this one okay
and i'll i'll try to open up the youtube
as well so i can see you
guys in the comments okay i will try to
do that as well
okay all right so this is the position
and here we go white to play and win
pretty crazy position there are no puns
on the board a lot of minor pieces
and the question is what to do what to
do here
in order to try to make uh some progress
here for white
so i want to give you a little bit of
time to think and see
if you can come up come up with the
right solution here
so what would be the right plan here
okay
you have to try to come up with the idea
to try to create
a way either to mate or win opponents
queen okay these are the two options
here for you
win opponent's queen or come up with the
checkmate
so let's see here what can we do here
what do you think
will be the right plan in this position
okay let's see here
okay i hope you guys can hear me i just
increase my volume
hopefully it's good um
all right now the first move here
what do we have in this position we're
going to start off with
we don't have too many options so we're
going to go for
knight
to a5 check okay knight a5
check and now to see where is the king
gonna go if the king goes to a2
we have a simple rook a4 mate
okay so that's not gonna work he has to
go here no choice
okay he has to go here no choice
and now what can you do here bishop c5
check forcing the key to go to a2 and
now
following it up with the same mating
mechanism
rook a4 mate
so he's gonna try to make it more
difficult of course by playing
knight a five king two
c3 king goes to c3
okay one second guys i'm gonna try to
fix my microphone so let's see here
uh let's see here
i'm gonna
okay hopefully i wanna make sure you
guys can hear me so
this is all the way uh let's see here
okay okay one second guys just a second
uh i want to fix the sound hello we are
back guys and
now let's see if you can find the
finishing idea of this game
see if you can find the finishing point
perfect thank you
it's good it's good you're good you're
live
all right all right guys we are back so
let's take a look okay
and now we reach this position here so
this is where i want you now to find the
right idea okay
so what would be the right idea in this
position
what would be the right idea to try to
break through here okay
so let's see what can we do here
what can we do here to find the winning
condition i have the chat open
so it's going to be very interactive
here i'm going to be asking you for the
for your answers okay now i hope you
guys can hear me
i hope you can hear me well now let's
see here
what's the move here why to play and
what will be the finishing touch in this
insane end game position so
i'm i'm watching for your solution here
guys type it in a chat let's see
now knight c6 chess king no no no no
chess king
chess king you have to think okay chess
king i think i know this is strong adi
you know
but it's not you know you have to do
something special
something extraordinary
now what can we do here we have to
figure out a way guys
to to come up with something special
[Music]
okay one second guys
okay guys so we're back and sorry a
little technical technical uh
the difficulties today but okay we got
it i think
so let me know if you can hear me guys
can you hear me well
bishop f4 i mean that's a possibility
that's a possibility but what else what
else you have here
something extraordinary okay chess king
is good okay owen crawford good
okay perfect all right yes we're glad we
fixed it because we want to make sure
you can hear me well here okay so what's
the move here
i don't see the solution except okay i
see one correct solution
rook b4 perfect perfect absolutely
rook b4 now the idea behind this movie
is oh sorry
i got to do it here rook takes rook to
b4
the point if he takes with the king you
have a nice
check okay and picking up the material
and then you have to demonstrate your
technique technique of checkmating with
the bishop at night
how many of the people who are watching
we have 45 people how many people can
check me with the bishop at night
can you type in a chat if you think you
can do this
checkmate with the bishop at night so
if he takes like this now we have a view
beautiful bishop d2 idea checking the
king
and winning the queen because the
knight is covering a very important two
squares you cannot
keep contact with the knight okay
but that's not gonna work so now he's
gonna play queen to g8
queen to g8 because he wants to cover
the b3 square okay
he wants to cover the b3 square and now
what can you do now he wants to cover
the b3 square and what can
we do here i want to see the solution
here
very very easy okay well it depends for
some people it might be easy some people
might be hard so we have to see guys
so now what is the idea here
what is the idea here we can try to do
here
and now now bishop the two he runs
bishop d2 he runs okay
there is no mate here guys you're
letting him escape
you don't want that to happen so what's
the finishing touch here
all right
ben nain banane is very good banane
finds it rook b3 correct banane
mm-hmm now queen takes
b3 and now bishop d2 check
and the king cannot stay here and now
if you go to c4 knight takes on c4 king
c2 cannot go anywhere
and now again once again we reach this
position where you have to show a
technique
how to win this tell me please what is
the key
idea when you're trying to check my with
the bishop at night what is the key idea
that you have to know here
what's the idea do in order to make this
okay i hope the volume is okay guys so
now
the winning idea would be at the end the
w maneuver okay
you will have to figure out the w
maneuver
okay all right so we'll go
at some point i will show you how to win
this as well okay
get the king to the corner okay let me
let me show you okay let me show you how
to do this okay you go here
now he's gonna go here we go here
let's say here we go here
so you're gonna you're gonna drive this
king to the corner he's gonna go here
okay
now you have to figure out how to cover
the square
so to that to have for that to happen
you're going to go here
here now knight c7 you're covering this
light square
he goes here and now bishop b8 so that
way the king can no longer go to e8 and
now he has to go here
and this is where you start the famous w
maneuver i've done a video on this okay
a couple of years ago guys
what i demonstrated the w maneuver and
this is
once again how you do it goes here check
goes here here here here
he goes here check forcing it back you
go here here
here here check your knight only moves
like the w
remember only like a w
check
now you make a waiting move check
and a checkmate one more attempt here he
can try to do
guys so again this is your final
position remember
one more idea he can try to do
here he can play
he can try to escape here okay then you
go here
now you go 97. now he goes here he's
trying to escape okay
he's trying to go here we got this under
control and now we cut
we cut the squares okay
now we go here squares are under control
we go here check
can't go to c8 c7 so has to go here now
we go here
bishop c7
check
king f8 we're back to the w
and now here's we're gonna need a
waiting move here okay
now he goes here king
h6 and now we have a mate
on f6 okay
and that's your idea to remember okay
that's your final
position once again i want to
demonstrate to you the technique
how to win with the bishop and knight
okay
so remember that okay
all right very good let's move on to the
next position
anybody anybody in a chat here have
questions
about this position how to win this
yeah you have to drive the king to the
color of the dark square bishop correct
correct tracy absolutely you have to
drive that king if you had a light
square bishop
you would have drive that king to the
light corner and then made him there
okay
okay let's move on okay we got a lot
more work to do today
let's see here
all right
yeah yeah these are going to be
really really insane you know like the
title for this class
these are going to be some very insane
positions that it doesn't look like you
should win
but you're gonna come up with the extra
ordinary ideas to win the game
like in this one like in this one here
guys look
white to play and win
okay how can you try to win this
position it looks like the knights are
trapped
it looks like it's going to be very very
difficult to do anything here
but let's see here why to play and win
what can we do here so i want to give
you a couple of minutes to think so you
can find the solution
well let's not go for the immediate
checks now i know you guys want to give
a check but don't rush okay
sometimes you don't want to just go for
the check you want to wait
you want to wait for the right idea
so what can you do here you want to wait
for the right
idea the right opportunity here
so let's see here no it's not rook b1
the move it's not group b1 guys
yeah rp1 okay he can he can move king a5
i think
i know you're uh saying this but what
are you going to do after this
your knight is pinned you cannot check
you know
so you don't want to do that
yeah you don't want to do that
what's the other idea we can try to do
here
we have to figure out look at all your
pieces look at your knights what can you
do here
wait for him to capture and pin his
queen
okay uh change the board color well uh
don't you guys like the black background
i mean
yesterday people were saying they didn't
like the white background so
i changed it to dark one so
okay rook e1 wait rookie one
uh rookie one i can just take on e5 guys
yeah i think the board is okay yeah
wait for him to capture and then pin
okay
uh okay let's do it a little bit more
concrete
yeah i i agree i agree with the you know
the background the background is okay
guys it looks much much better the white
one it's harder to see you know
all right i don't see the answer yet
guys come on let's try to find this okay
what is the idea
rook e1 rookie one okay but i
i don't have to capture it's not like i
must capture right i can do something
else
i can i don't know can i run away
can i do something like this and run
away guys i don't have to fall for that
trick
i know you want me to take so you can
discovery check and win
i know you want to do this but
better better than rook d1 here
let's see here
yeah 96 let's do it but let's see here
96 check okay king a4 guys
yeah i i don't know why you're making me
go to the c5 i don't want to go to c5
plus if i go to c5 chess king if i go to
c5 you have knight d3
okay i don't want to do that chess king
all right so knight d6 i'll go king a4
okay
all right what's the move here i i still
don't see the right move here
i haven't seen the solution yet
all right the first move is to try to
give a check
it's a hint for you guys the first move
is a hint for you it's a check
so how are you gonna check his king here
that's the question
so that's the question okay knight c3
correct
now let's make a few things clear if you
go here
you lose the queen game is over also
if he goes here it's actually made
that's beautiful
if he goes here now this is a problem
tell me why is this a problem
why is this a problem if i go here
we use the rook right check
he goes here we go 95 check
and guess what thank you very much okay
so now he has to go here king c5
and now here is you have to come up with
absolute
brilliant move what is that
absolute brilliant move here that is
going to help you to win this game
if he goes kc5 i want to see that move
here
i'm sure i'm sure we're going to see the
right move here
what is the correct move here guys
what is the correct move
let me see here brian young
brian young okay rook h5 i mean i can't
go 93 i wish i could do it see it's not
even letting us do it it's illegal
that's why
you're pinned you're pinned uh
your pin guys you can't just do that you
cannot play illegal move okay
so correct movies rook h5 fantastic now
let's understand what's going on the
king cannot move if he goes here he gets
forked
if he goes here he gets forked okay
if he tries to maintain the pin he gets
forked
okay so many many ways he gets forked
so what should we do now to see this
okay
so now rook h5 now
he you know and and wherever you put the
queen actually you're gonna get either
discovery check or a fork
so the only move is this this is the
only move queen f1
in order to control and put it somewhere
that it's not gonna get forked that's
the only move
and now you're gonna find the second
quiet move the first quiet move
was rook 2 h5 but now you're going to
find a second quiet move
to cement your advantage
now what do you do it's about
calculating guys it's about calculating
and finding this quiet moves
okay it's all about
quiet move here to put him into that
suksavang
which move will put him in a sook swank
here guys it's not a it's not a
drastic move here it's not a drastic
move it's more like a quiet move
to set up the suksavang okay you want to
do the suksavang
i'm watching i'm watching the chat i'm
hoping to see the solution and there we
go we got it
colt lunge finds it first and then see
darth finds it correct
pratam finds it absolutely
rook h4 quiet move
now eyeballing the rook c4 move if the
queen moves away
where is the queen gonna go now he
doesn't have that many squares to go to
and also we are setting up another
mating mechanism knight d7
in fact this is our threat our threat is
to play knight d7 and mate here
okay so that is the problem for black
so now he's gonna try to go for a
there is nothing he can do you're
threading 97 czech or roxy forger so he
cannot do anything so he's going to go
queen to f7
sacrificing the queen in the hopes that
you would take it and then this will be
a steal mate
see this will be a disaster because you
know
there's no you know it's a still mate
but are we gonna take the queen
are we really gonna do that of course
not
of course not what are you gonna do
instead
to break the steel mate and win the game
what you're gonna do to break the steel
mate and win this game
knight d7 fantastic the king has no
squares to go to
everything is taken takes
king takes d5 d4 c4 everything is taken
and now this is over excellent
all right so this was a quiet move
look at this this whole game was a quiet
move
check sorry you play knight c3 check
forcing the king to go here on c5
and now rook h5 quiet move
he goes here you have a fork
he goes here you have a fork
so he has to go queen to f1
and now you play the other quiet move
rook h4
setting up rook c4 and knight d7 ideas
okay
all right very good guys
excellent okay very very good
let's move on to the next game okay next
end game
okay i'm gonna clear the board
okay this is a very practical position
so
let me show you
because something like this could easily
happen in your games okay
so you would need to you would need to
know what to do
okay
all right white to play
and win why
to play and win how you gonna do this
how you can try to win this
how do you a great question from great
wolf how do you decide
whether to look for a quiet move or
forcing move in a previous position
given position well
uh well if you look at the forcing moves
and they don't lead to anything
then you switch gears and you look for a
quiet move okay
you look for a forcing moves and if that
doesn't work you switch for the quiet
moves okay so that's uh that's how i
would do it okay
that's simply how i would do it i would
look for the forcing moves first you
always have to look for checks and
captures
and if that doesn't works doesn't work
then you switch for the other moves
more quiet moves and
but quiet moves they could be incredibly
strong okay
they could be incredibly strong so you
have to remember
all right what we got now in this
position everybody in the chat saying
queen f5 queen f5 queen f5 okay but did
you look at the defense when you say
queen f5
did you guys find blocks best defense
pin the rook and the king i understand
that i understand that brian but what's
the best defense
you know what's the best defense you
you you don't think i just set this up
for you to find queen f5
i know you guys much stronger than that
so i'm not gonna set up a one move win
for you
so what's the correct move here king
h8 fantastic if you take now look at
this
look at this four key okay and winning
material
if you take with this look at this now
look at this incredible defense you see
it
sucking the bishop sacrificing and now
if you capture
it's going to be a steal mate okay
incredible absolutely incredible defense
by black
sacrificing the rook and then
sacrificing the bishop
but what are you going to do we're not
going to let this game
just slip away do we we're still going
to try to win this
but how but how we can try to win this
so let's see he plays king h8 what can
we do here guys
what can we do here
queen e5 check correct if he goes here
we just come here and queen g7 mate
that's good so here's go i'm going to go
here
now what do you do
now what do you do
okay
king h7 check now correct
if we go back here you can just simply
take
so has to go here
now we have to continue
again if you give block a break he puts
a bishop on f7 rook g6 is going to be a
draw
so you don't have time to give a break
if you give one break like this
check that's a draw already okay
rook f7 it's just going to be a draw
so that's the idea
now what to do in this position
now what to do
now let me look at the chat here queen
e4 correct
now he cannot play rook g6 because you
have queen takes g6
so has to go here
now we gotta try to do what we're
getting closer guys we're getting step
by step
we're getting closer now to win this
[Music]
game
now we gotta try to pin him so we go
queen to h
e5 now threatening king h6
threatening king h6 and take the rook so
he has to go here no choice
and now we're getting closer guys this
is like a ladder you're walking on a
ladder and getting closer to him okay
and now queen f5 pratam
correct pratam now he goes here
continue continue john abraham how are
you going to do it
let's get it let's get it guys you're so
close
you're so close now let's do it queen f6
bravo threatening king h6 okay
threatening king h6 and picking up on g7
and it's gonna be a mate mating
mechanism okay
so that's why he goes
he cannot do anything guys and if he
goes here
what is the solution here what is the
solution here guys
i'm sure you see it pratam yes
excellent job guys very methodical
step-by-step okay methodical
step-by-step approach here to win this
absolutely incredible position but it
doesn't look like you're gonna be able
to win this position
after this move it looks like it's gonna
be a draw
but you can win this by coming up with
this incredible
staircase idea with the queen incredible
staircase
to win this game all right perfect guys
so let's now move on to the next
position
anybody has questions in a chat anybody
has questions about this position you
understand the approach
i'll show you one more time if you take
draw
if you take this way incredible defense
draw
so you're not gonna do that you're not
gonna do any of that check
and then you win the rook and mate so it
has to go to h7
check and you take and mate on g7
so it has to go to rook g7 now check
sorry if you go here it's just a draw
so you will go queen 2 e4 and get up
there
pin it come closer pin it
come closer and then you have the mate
all right perfect
very good excellent we're gonna move on
to the next position okay
very interesting thank you thank you
petke petk 1982
you just get closer you gotta work
together queen and queen
they work together to get closer
absolutely pin it to win it oven perfect
yeah you know that saying yeah pin it to
win it and at the end you win it
all right let's get another one here
guys
okay this is a nice one
this is a nice one again coordinating
your pieces
coordinating your pieces is very
important okay
all right
okay guys the next position okay the
next position
is a very nice study composed in 1905
okay 1905 and this is by the brothers
platonov brothers they were very very
famous composers
platonov brothers okay so white
to play and win
okay you gotta figure out the way to win
this game
this is by platon of brothers okay
so how we gonna try to do this
you know of course we have to do
something with this queen
first of all it looks like we are just
losing okay we the queen is
you know queen versus knight and rook i
mean this just
looks like a losing you know but
what to do here you can try to actually
win this position
but you have to show me how
no queen for white
where are you getting these positions
from this is a this is incredible
i have this book it's a very old book
okay very old book
here we go you see it it's like from
1982
so it's it's a russian book with
kasparian studies okay
so it's uh uh you know
i'm fluent in russian so i'm you know
reading this
and uh setting that up for you okay this
is you know i i i wasn't able to find
anything in english like this
so this is a special studies book by
kasparian
okay
yeah this is like a russian book it's
called a beautiful studies okay
very old book as you can see you know
but
i love this book i've been using this
book for a very long time
it's got some incredible studies
all right uh well okay
let's see what we got a chess king has a
solution
chess king has something okay uh
john abraham rook b7 is that why you're
so strong because you speak russian
i i don't know i'm not sure but you know
russian is you know it's a good language
to know
but uh i don't know if you know uh you
know
if that has anything to do with being
strong or not but
i did train and grew up you know in a
soviet
uh era where you know i had a lot of
access to
this good russian chess books you know
all right
what do we got here what are we got here
i think i see the first move here so
good job chess king
but the question is if you calculated
everything
okay now check if you go here
thank you very much winning the queen if
you go here again how are you gonna
force the win
show me how are you going to force the
wing guys
type type in the chat so i can see you
see it now
check correct part time correct
and now check correct
so that's why he's gonna go here
now now what's the follow-up
now what's the follow-up guys
check correct now the white has black
has two options
he can't go here again once again you
have the knight g5
so if he goes king d7
then you go to cafe and you're threading
knight g5 to trap the queen
and uh yeah basically this is uh
this actually transposes into the main
line so we're gonna get this okay
all right so here king is seven
now you don't want to go here
because of this idea boom
and you actually lose now because d and
h pawns are stronger than
your pawns you know
yeah these are just too strong okay
all right so what are we doing what are
we doing here check
he goes here this is an incredible idea
you have here let's see here
now rook p7 partham rook p7 what's the
follow up the rook p7 he goes here
partham
now what do we do
now this is correct but here you need
this move okay
your absolutely need this incredible
idea
kemi ko kami ko finds it maxi grubs
finds it
mohit kumar andre chavaria
correct brian young absolutely guys
and everybody else who said rook f7
absolutely look at that move
absolutely fantastic move here takes
winning the queen and now what is your
threat here
what is your threat guys do you see the
threat
you have a you have a nice threat here
so he's gonna play
h6 let's say okay to cover the g5 square
okay to cover the g5 square and now what
do we do
now what do we do here
mm-hmm yeah actually it's a zuksavan so
black has to move and he plays h6
and now h6 weakens a very
important square g6 okay so what are we
going to do
what are we going to do cafe check
correct he goes here
and now we want to zook him right how
are we going to zook him here
we want to make sure he runs out of
moves okay
we want to make sure he runs out of
moves because his queen cannot move here
right
so let's see rook f7 h6
actually sorry sorry he plays here he
has to go here
because if he goes here you just go
knight f4
hitting the queen it takes check
and you pick it up on f3
and if he goes here look at this lovely
mate here
look at this lovely mate okay
so he has to play here because of that
and now we need a waiting move here
we need a waiting move here guys
yeah i told you yeah this is going to be
a little insane stuff
a3 waiting move he goes here
a4 soup savang okay
suk savank right here guys if he plays
h5
now g5 square is weakened what are you
gonna do
what are you gonna do now
now you're gonna go knight g5 owen
yes trapping that queen and winning the
game
so he's got no choice he's in a zook
he's in a zook he's gonna go here now
and now what's the idea he's in a zook
here guys
what is the idea yep
praham correct knight f4 hitting the
queen
queen cannot take it we had seen this in
a previous line check and pick up on f3
and if he goes here incredible
knight g6 mate okay incredible knight g6
mating the king and
you know winning the game absolutely
okay
it's all about putting the opponent into
a zuksavang okay
zuk sawang let's do this one more time
because it was insanely complicated you
know
check
if he goes here it's just knight g5 so
i'm gonna show you the best defense so
king is seven
that's bad because of queen e6 so we go
check
rook f7 now if he takes we have knight
g5
okay
so he has to go h6 to cover the g5
square
now you give a check if he goes here
just knight f4 and knight g6
wins the game so he has to go king 2
d7 then you play this was incredible
what is the move here guys
a3 parham a4
and now he goes here and boom chopping
the queen
he has to go here and now we go back to
the other line knight f4 yeah i would
recommend you set up the position on a
chess board
okay you set up the position on the
chess board and try to calculate
and try to do it without moving the
pieces okay
first you try to do it without moving
the pieces and then you will move the
pieces after that okay
so first you want to make sure you don't
move the pieces okay
but you want to set it up on a
chessboard and actually do it that way
all right all right guys okay
and the last one guys the last one it's
not gonna be as
insane on this one okay i promise you
but it's still very nice okay all right
i hope you enjoyed this one okay i
really hope you enjoy this one okay this
this is a really nice position okay
all right let's go here
uh
and it's a little bit similar
dynamics at least the dynamics are very
similar
all right
white to play and win why to play and
win
another very very beautiful position by
platonov okay
another famous famous composer
v platonov
v platonov is is this is just his one
the previous one there were there were
two brothers
platonos so they both did it together
but this one is just the platoon of
from 1905 white to play
and win okay
all right let's take a look very
beautiful i'm i am glad you like it
gaming
a y gaming nice got to go thank you
billy thanks for hanging out see you
next time okay would you play a match
with
me please uh pratam i do my own
streaming and i'll be happy to play you
make sure you
follow my twitch gm varacobian
okay and uh and then i have sessions
where i play people so you can do that
okay so let's see here uh
rookie eight okay the first move is
everybody is screaming rookie eight
correct
now i cannot take obviously because of
this
so if i go here
knight before obviously if i go here you
go here obviously
okay so has to go here
king d5
all right now he goes king d5 now what
do we do
now he goes knd5 uh
rama i will be happy to play
but you know basically when i'm when i'm
doing my own stream or
when i'm playing viewers you i'll be
happy to play
but right now we're just doing the
puzzles so
and end game so now what do we do here
guys we talk about something we talk
about something very
important here we talk about something
very very important here the quiet moves
remember
the quiet moves and here is an
incredible move you're going to find
pratham says d3 pratam
pratam what about uh
i don't know about this move pratam um
maybe maybe pratam but i'm not sure
maybe he runs pratam
can you run here can you run here pratam
i don't know i'm not sure about this
okay
all right so what's the move here guys
what is the move here
all right d3 pratam no d3 i think it is
a defense
good morning
uh tito roy i'm glad you're enjoying it
i'm glad you're enjoying it
welcome to your first class and
hopefully you'll be coming more often
okay
um no it's not d3 guys it's not d3
it's not d3 here it's something
different
it's a really really powerful move here
you want to do here
nah brook check i don't know i don't
know about the look check
stream srinivas
ah brian young brian young
finds it look at this move guys look at
this insane move here
now if he takes with the king chekka
and then we take this and we win the end
game four on three king and pawn end
game is winning
and if he takes with the queen now look
at this checker
check out and take a look at that guys
okay so rookie six
now what to do here after rookie six
it's
very tricky so he cannot take anyway
so he can play queen c4 by the way if he
takes here
why is this losing i want to see it in a
chat here why is this losing here guys
you can find this 30 seconds 30 seconds
what is the solution here
30 seconds guys what's the move here
rookie five correct check
winning the queen if he goes here let a
four key this way little fork it this
way
perfect so
he cannot take as well now he has to
play queen c4
but if he plays queen c4
now what do you do
yeah actually this is another
i'm sorry guys this is another insane
one
very similar to previous one okay
another insane move here
insane idea rook e4
tito roy yes if he takes
well here we have d3 winning
it takes now we have fork
and again we're winning because of the
extra pawn okay
so what this gives us if he goes back to
c6
which is going to do this gives us the
quiet
move that we wanted to play earlier
the quiet move that we wanted you to
play earlier remember
when we had a rook on e6 the quiet move
here no no c4 he runs
c4 he runs okay
d3 fantastic yes now threatening
rookie five mate okay
and if he takes and if he goes here
remember in the previous line he had
this he doesn't have it now because we
have this check
okay so d3 now he has to go here
only move again threat is rookie five so
he has to go here
and now we play
now what's the solution after this move
check what what's the idea guys you
should see it
check forcing him to go here and now
how do we win this now how we get into
the winning end game
nazir nazir correct nazir check
he has to take it check
take and take this is easily winning
guys king and pawn end games in an extra
pound like this are
always winning okay and they're quite
quite easily one here so here you will
just simply come up
if you place b5 c3 uh
yeah you just you just simply
you can't even just wait until the king
moves away you're going to go king e4 h5
you go here
and just go forward and you just push
yeah it's just it's just either easily
one okay
absolutely yeah i know brian super crazy
yeah i thought
okay insane end games maybe something
appropriate you know this might be
something appropriate
but anyway guys i'm i'm glad you enjoyed
it
incredible book i agree i agree ram
incredible book incredible studies okay
and uh it's something you cannot find
you know you know a lot of people try to
find something similar
in english but it's very very hard okay
i'm glad you guys
enjoy the class thank you everybody for
stopping by
and watching this make sure you can you
can watch this later on a youtube
channel
and i will be back again with more
classes
on thursday evening make sure you come
okay thursday at 6 30 okay
6 30 to 8 30 on thursday okay all right
excellent job everybody bye bye